[Music]
we're making a demo for oculus connect
that's called bullet train right that's
what are we doing we're bullets and
training bullets and I really respect
Rob it's it's a nice departure from the
last thing we did showdown you know
which was more of a linear experience
very high fidelity we've jumped off the
fidelity even more so and it's highly
dynamic yeah we kind of wanted to take
the same tone from that yeah yeah
bullets and slow-motion in it yeah and
the fact that this is super interactive
super dynamic right we don't we don't
even have like just the singular track
for you know camera to worry about it's
like they can go anywhere do anything
teleporting all around you know an
oculus has their controllers but they're
kind of developing that yeah and we
wanted to turn that into something a
little more interactive one thing led to
another and here we are in put your
hands out put a little strap on your
hand fast what exactly happened today we
had our executive with you and that was
fun this is awesome oh my god
so that ah this is awesome I think they
loved it right yeah and we got some
great feedback from the guys um some of
it we know and was on our list some some
new stuff to think about
yeah overall I think it's great yeah
we're pretty much as expected it man
it's a little stressful it's a good
party process for yeah so small
victories we got no comments on branding
or music or tones so we're all we're in
good spot without it so it's like
there's all technical bugs they yeah
they like the outro so I think if we
dress it up with what we're thinking
it'll be fantastic now every time we sit
down to review unless there's terrible
bugs I get really excited and like oh we
could do this we could do that right and
you see that passion just feed off each
other we're very lucky we were able to
pull lots of awesome people to form this
team kind of out of nowhere right and
there's a lot of things they've been
able to speak out so we're able to do a
lot more with Vitas and stuff so we're
kind of maturing the technology a little
bit you can show that everything works a
lot more optimally you know we have the
stereo instancing yes everything all
faster what we've been able to do with
the environment like this the station
looks good we're really hitting that but
putting that realism in VR right which
is really amazing for presents you know
if they're a gamer those never see where
they are I think this is gonna convince
them that there's some magical things
ahead right this is VR for gamers
[Music]
you